[Music]
I have to trust my instincts and Harry
was perfect for this part you can
practically see it from here what
dunkirk director Christopher Nolan
praises Harry Styles on his acting debut
playing a soldier named Alex in the
intense war drama as a director I have
to trust my instincts of my ability to
figure out who's the right guy for the
part I was new to Harry I mean I'd heard
his name for my kids you know but I
wasn't very familiar with him but what I
was seeing was a very charismatic guy
but who clearly had truthfulness salty
in his ability to perform as a film
actor and you know I mean when I cast
Heath Ledger as the Joker it raised a
lot of eyebrows and cause a lot of
comment I have to trust my instincts and
Harry was perfect for this part and I
think he pulled it off with incredible
grace and reality I was just talking to
Chris and he said you know casting
hairiness for me was like a stanky
Fletcher as the Joker what does it mean
to you to hear those words
Chris says this amazing way of making
you feel you know so welcoming so
you're working and never lets the
surroundings kind of intimidate you
always feels very intimate while you're
while you're filming zone never really
allows that to kind of take over from
the important stuff which is obviously
the film that you're making in the story
nolan opened up to ET about creating
that intimate environment on set i mean
where they're screaming girls did you
have to have a secretive set we always
have a secretive set anyway so we're
sort of used to shutting things off and
really trying to create our own world
harry was very committed and determined
to just being one of the guys coming
there and learning what he could from
the more experienced people around him
do you have code words for the actors
and a secretive sentence all done with
numbers and you know all the rest so you
know cool shoots at numbers and wins it
there are a lot of things we have in
play on anything to protect you know the
actors from prying eyes
[Music]
you